this was an accounting scam heather
dubrow claims she was scammed out of
millions making the allegations on a new
podcast big story he run through it for
us what you want to tease well if you
look at my Instagram at Heather Dubrow
you will see a picture of Jennifer
Lindsey Bell who conned Terry and I out
of almost two million dollars the Real
Housewives of Orange County Star says it
was a long-time advisor who set up the
deal gone wrong and only et was behind
the scenes as Heather films the episode
we thought we were making a very
calculated risk-free investment and it
turned out not to be so and it really it
comes down to a matter of trust who do
you trust who can you trust and you know
you think you have people that you've
known for years and years and it turns
out they're not who you think they are
so listen to Heather dubrow's world and
I'm going to give you the entire lowdown
on what happened to me and Terry we're
putting this story out there so not just
to tell everyone hey we lost almost two
million dollars but you know we feel you
know responsibility that we found out
later that these people that scammed us
have scammed other people for millions
and millions of dollars and if Terry and
I don't come out and go public with this
they will do it again Terry and I are
offering a twenty-five-thousand-dollar
reward for any information that's
leading to the arrest of Jennifer
Lindsay bail I mean come on this
shouldn't happen to anyone let's get her